SHANGHAI NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE
ENDURED A BRUTAL MONTHS-LONG
LOCKDOWN.
SELINA WANG TAKES A CLOSER LOOK.
>> SPRINTING CAN SHOPPING BAGS,
RESIDENTS RACING TO GET OUT,
AFTER MORE THAN TWO MONTHS OF A
BRUTAL CITY-WIDE LOCKDOWN,
SHANGHAI IS FINALLY CRACKING
OPEN THE SEAL.
THE CITY'S MAIN TRAIN STATION
PACKED WITH PEOPLE TRYING TO
ESCAPE, BUT ACTUALLY GETTING OUT
OF HERE IS A TREACHEROUS
JOURNEY.
THE CITY SAYS IT WILL FULLY
RESUME TRANSPORTATION TODAY.
BUT EARLIER, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SEEN TREKKING MILES ACROSS
HIGHWAYS, DRAGGING THEIR LUGGAGE
OR STRAPPING IT TO BIKES.
EVEN JOURNEYS OF DOZENS OF MILES
OR MORE NOT SWAYING THEIR
DETERMINATION.
THE TRAIN STATION PARKING LOT
HAS BECOME A CAMP SITE.
SOME LEAVING DAYS EARLIER THAN
THEIR DEPARTURE TIME, TERRIFIED
THEY COULD BE LOCKED DOWN AGAIN
IF THEY STAY AT HOME.
THE MASSES OUTSIDE THE TRAIN
STATION, A STARK CONTRAST TO THE
REST OF SHANGHAI.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS STILL
REMAIN LOCKED IN.
BUT EVEN THE LUCKY ONES ALLOWED
OUT FACE A LAUNDRY LIST OF
RESTRICTIONS.
THERE ARE CHECKPOINTS
EVERYWHERE.
>> THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT
FREEDOM.
>> THIS SHANGHAI RESIDENT AND
HER SON WHO WISHED TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS FOR FEAR OF
PERSECUTION FROM AUTHORITIES
WERE FINALLY ALLOWED OUT AFTER
MORE THAN 80 DAYS.
HER ONLY SOLACE IS SEEING HER
SON OUTSIDE AND SMILING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A LONG TIME.
>> MY CHILD NOW HAS DEPRESSION
BECAUSE OF THE LOCKDOWN.
HE STARTED WAKING UP AT NIGHT
AND CRYING AND SHOUTING AND
SAYING THERE WERE PEOPLE WEARING
MASKS IN HIS BEDROOM, AND HE
STOPPED EATING.
>> THAT HARSH REALITY, MILES
AWAY FROM WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
WANTS TO SHOW.
WATCH THIS STATE TV REPORTER
PULL THE MICROPHONE AND CAMERA
AWAY DURING A LIVE INTERVIEW
WHEN THE RESIDENT STARTS TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE LOCKDOWN.
SHE SAYS, I HAVE NEVER LIVED
THROUGH ANYTHING LIKE THIS,
BEING LOCKED INSIDE YOUR HOME
AND NOT ALLOWED TO GO OUT.
WHAT A BIG JOKE.
OFFICIALS SAY THE CITY WILL
START RETURNING TO NORMAL IN
JUNE, BUT RESIDENTS ARE
DOUBTFUL.
>> THIS DOES FEEL LIKE ENDLESS,
ENDLESS NIGHTMARE.
>> HER FREEDOM LASTED LESS THAN
A WEEK.
ONE COVID CASE WAS FOUND NEAR
HER, SO SHE'S BACK TO LOCKDOWN.
FOR OVER TWO MONTHS, SHANGHAI
HAS HAD ITS FREEDOM TAKEN AWAY.
RESIDENTS IMPRISONED AT HOME OR
FORCED INTO QUARANTINE CENTERS
LIKE THESE.
NO ONE KNOWS WHEN THIS NIGHTMARE
WILL FULLY END.
JAKE, PEOPLE IN SHANGHAI, THEY
ARE RELIEVED BUT THEY'RE ALSO IN
HUGE DISBELIEF.
THEY HAVE REALLY BEEN LEFT
TRAUMATIZED BY THIS MONTHS-LONG
LOCKDOWN AND IT'S REALLY ERODED
PEOPLE'S TRUST IN THE
GOVERNMENT, AND EVEN THOUGH MOST
OF SHANGHAI'S 25 MILLION ARE
FINALLY ABLE TO STEP OUTSIDE
TODAY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
STILL REMAIN LOCKED INSIDE.
THESE LAST FEW MONTHS HAVE
REALLY BEEN A WAKE-UP CALL TO
SHANGHAI THAT IN AUTHORITARIAN
CHINA, EVEN IF YOU LIVE IN THE